Hello, this is Steve Kaufmann
and today I have a special guest.
It is Stefani Kostadinova, who
is originally, in fact, is now
living in Bulgaria, but has
traveled to many countries and
we are going to talk about...
and has a, a background, I should say,
academic background in language learning.
And so we're gonna talk
about language learning.
But remember, if you enjoy
these videos, please subscribe.
Click on the bell for notifications.
If you follow me on a podcast
service, please leave a comment.
So Stefani, hello.
Good morning.
At least in my time.
Hi.
Hi, Steve.
It's great to be here on your channel.
Could you, Stefani, give us a
brief introduction to you and,
and your activities as, as it
concerns learning languages?
Yeah.
I have been into learning languages for
a very long time and I actually grew up
in a monolingual household surrounded
by a lot of dialects, uh, which is
normal in Bulgaria, but truly just one
language at home and not really much
that I would hear outside of my home.
So for me it was a journey that
was about the love of languages.
And I liked it even at school where, you
know, I often argue that it's not the best
way to learn the way that is presented
at school, but I enjoyed it even then.
And I would always do this outside
activities, you know, outside of
school and you know, a lot of getting
a lot of input into language learning.
And for me it was really Spanish
that opened the floodgates
because with Spanish, which was
not available at my school at the
time, and I really wanted to learn.
And with that language I
figured out, you know, how to
learn by myself and everything.
And from then on I'd added more and
more languages as I find it fascinating.
And, um, you know, a number of things
that you said there are quite interesting.
One is that you grew up in
a monolingual family, right?
Uh, and I remember, I remember I was
at a Polyglot Conference in Montreal
and talking to 600 people and I said,
how many people here grew up in a mo...
grew up in a family that had more
than one language, and practically
no one put their hand up.
So the myth that you have to
be raised in a multilingual
family it's simply not true.
It can be a positive factor, but
it's certainly not necessary.
Yeah.
Uh, the second thing is Bulgaria,
you say a lot of different dialects.
Mm-hmm.
How different are these
dialects from each other?
Are they still Bulgarian or are they
different sort of slavi languages?
Right, so they are, they're still
Bulgarian, or at least that's how
they're classified by linguists.
If, if somebody from the eastern part
of the country, like closer to the
Black Sea or something goes to the
Southwest, for example, and like,
especially in villages where the dialects
are very strong, chances are they're
not gonna be able to understand much.
So, I really, it, it's, I do think it's,
uh, the same language, but you know,
sometimes we don't understand each other.
If we are speaking in.
Yeah.
So, and, and of course Macedonian of
course is a separate language, right.
But is has some similarity with Bulgarian.
Is there sort of a gradual transition
from Bulgarian to Macedonian and
then from Macedonian to say Serbian?
Is there a, a, a gradual, uh, progression
there, or are they all distinct?
Yeah, so with Macedonian, There's a whole
lot of political issue there, um, mm-hmm.
. So I'm gonna try to kind of skate
around that as, as well as I can and
not really get too involved into that.
But, um, generally linguists disagree.
Um, there's quite a lot of, you
know, some say that, many actually
say that it is really the same
language, kind of part of a dialect
continuum, the way that Norwegian
and Swedish would be in Danish maybe.
Um mm-hmm . So it's kind of
a dialect continuum between
Macedonian and Bulgarian.
And most linguists say that.
And of course there's a lot of like other
views which are mainly driven by politics.
And again, I don't wanna touch that.
Um, but really depends where you are from.
I would say like what part
of Bulgaria you are from.
Um, mm-hmm.
for example, there is actually a region
in Bulgaria that's called Macedonia.
Um, as well as in Greece of
course, but in Greece they mostly
speak Greek and the region of
Bulgaria that's called Macedonia.
And what in the Republic of
Macedonia is spoken uh, there's like
quite a lot of similarity there.
Obviously in, in towns, cities it is
not so much, but in villages it's like
they speak almost, almost the same.
Um, but if you look at Northeast
Bulgaria, they wouldn't be able to
understand Macedonian very well.
Just because they're much
further away from the border.
So it's kind of, yeah, the dialects
really play into question there.
But, and with Serbian, cause
you mentioned Serbian as well.
I would say that Macedonian as
in like what is spoken in, um,
the country of Macedonia perhaps
borrows a lot from Serbian.
I, I would say.
So there's...
that interesting uh, kind
of dynamic that's happening.
Yeah, it's, mm-hmm.
, certainly quite a lot of exchange.
So, yes.
And you know, it's interesting is
in French, the mixed vegetable dish
is called ... did you know that?
Yeah.
This refers to the fact that
there's such a variety of
languages spoken in the Balkans.
I guess.
I don't know.
So from a background of all these
different languages and dialects,
you go out and learn other languages.
Can you tell us how many languages you
speak and what was your experience on your
path towards learning these languages?
Yeah, so for me, I, I always
distinguish between two things, like
how many I speak and how many I learn.
Um mm-hmm.
and
good, good advice.
Yes.
Yeah.
I usually, I say currently
that I speak eight.
And for me, it's speak kind of, I kind
of feel comfortable to say I speak a
language at around the intermediate level.
Uh, when I'm a beginner,
I don't feel comfortable.
So yeah, that's, I would say that
out of those I would, I'm fluent in
five and intermediate in three, and
I study a couple of more currently
Persian and Russian, but I don't
say I speak them because they're
just in their beginning stages.
Although Russian is weird 'cause I,
I've always been able to understand
it just by virtue of being Slavic,
but not really speak it, so yeah.
It's, it's always been...
which are the five?
Which are the five?
The, the, yeah.
Where you're comfortable.
Yeah.
So obviously my native one
and English, and um, then
Spanish, Portuguese and Italian.
Yeah.
Mm-hmm.
very focused on the romance group,
and the three intermediate languages?
French, German, and Greek.
Aha.
Greek.
Very good.
Yeah.
Uh, first let me tell you that your use
of English to me is, is a model of how
people should speak in another language.
No one.
Would you think that you
are a native speaker.
Uh, because there's a trace of an
unidentifiable something accent that
says you're not a native speaker.
However, your use of phrasing, your use
of words is a hundred percent native.
Not only native, but at a higher
level than many, many natives.
And I've always said, you know,
people strive to be, you know,
mistaken for a native, forget it.
You're not gonna achieve that.
Focus instead on, on using words,
you know, in, in a, in a economical,
intelligent, accurate, uh, elegant way.
Mm-hmm.
And if you do those things and you
pull it off with a slight accent,
in fact, it sounds better than
if you try to not have an accent,
but you can't use words properly,
I think that should be the model.
When we learn a foreign language, you
speak English the way you speak English.
Very impressed.
Thank you.
Thanks so much for the kind words.
And actually, just to add, uh,
something quick here, I, I've never
been concerned with accents, which,
um, yeah, it's just never bothered me.
And also I think it really depends
kind of how your mouth moves.
It's really weird, but you know, when
your, when your mouth is moving a
certain way, thanks to your native
language, and sometimes it picks up
easier, some accents than others.
And I've noticed right from day one,
I had a really good accent in Greek,
better than my English accent, but my
Greek is much worse than my English.
So there, there's that.
I, I would think too, I, I think
particularly the vowels I would imagine.
Like Greek has very standard vowel
sounds like Spanish, Greek, and
I presume Bulgarian and English,
uh, like, uh, Swedish, uh, there's
a lot of dip thong Portuguese.
Mm-hmm.
dip thong type sounds
that are more different.
So it's gonna be more
difficult to to, to hit those.
Um, where...
did you study abroad or how did you
go about learning these languages?
.
Yeah.
So I did, uh, study abroad in, in the US.
I, I did a year in the US
when I was, um, 11th grade.
Mm-hmm.
And then I also, I went to an
American university here in Bulgaria.
And then after that, you know,
where the American university
here teaches entirely in English.
And then after that I got my
master's degree in the US again,
which was another two years.
In what subject?
In business.
Okay.
So yeah, it was, uh, I've lived
in the US quite for quite a while.
Um, but mm-hmm , the other languages
that I learned, I really learned kind of
before I went to the respective countries.
So I did an internship in Germany back in
the day, but I learned German before that.
Um, I worked in Spain for a year, but I
learned Spanish before I went to Spain.
So I wouldn't say that travel is the
key to my language learning, definitely
not, but I think that it must have
certainly helped with English back
in the day in high school, I guess.
But yeah, it was always for me,
learn the language before you land.
That's, that's just
how my life turned out.
Not there's anything wrong with doing it
the other way around, but in my case...
your way.
Your way is so much better because you
arrive, you hit the ground running,
you can make friends with the locals.
You can really build on it.
If you arrive hoping that just by
being there, you're gonna learn the
language, I think you're in most
cases going to be disappointed.
You basically settle into a pattern
of living with other expats and
speaking English the whole time.
So not good.
Just curious, I would imagine
that your pronunciation in
Spanish is very good as well.
You mentioned Greek.
Yeah, I would say better than in English.
Yeah, for sure.
for sure.
And and better than your German.
Even better...
I'm talking pronunciation.
And maybe you're German, maybe you're
more fluent in German, I don't know.
But because the point that you made about
the similarity of, of pronunciation.
I would imagine that you would find
Spanish pronunciation more natural to you.
Yes, yes.
Very much so.
Spanish, much more natural than French.
Much more natural than German.
yeah.
Mm-hmm.
. Yeah.
No, for sure.
Uh, and so what do you
do now in, in Bulgaria?
I work for a tech company.
I do strategy for them.
Mm-hmm.
And then at the same time I do this on
YouTube where, you know, I make videos
and I try to, I sometimes, uh, work
as a language coach, so I kind of have
two careers going on at the moment.
Okay.
We will leave a link to your channel.
Uh, tell us the name of your channel.
It's called Polyglot Secrets.
Polyglot Secrets.
And we'll leave a link and
people should go there.
And do you speak in English or do
you speak in a variety of languages?
I speak mostly in English.
I do have, um, a video in which I speak
in all the languages, uh, that I know.
And then I also have videos with other
polyglots where I've spoken other
languages, but it's mostly in English
'casue I feel like I can get it to more
people that way, you know, I can share
what I know with like a broader audience.
And the people who watch your
channel, are they watching your
channel to improve their English?
Are they watching your channel for
hints on how to learn languages
better and where are they from mostly?
Yeah.
So the people who watch my channel,
I believe most of them watch to
just in general, to learn how
to improve language learning.
Mm-hmm.
And actually the biggest number of people
that watch my channelare from  USthe.
Mm-hmm.
. And then there's a few other
countries, of course, Bulgaria,
the UK, Brazil, and Germany.
Those are my biggest geographies.
Mm-hmm.
. Um, but I do have, I've come across
people that I think are interested
in improving their English, because
I sometimes get comments such as,
can you please speak more slowly?
Um, you know, so I'm guessing that
there's also, uh, that kind of audience
as I sometimes get those comments.
But yeah, in general, I think like I try
to make my channel mostly about sharing
my experience and, you know mm-hmm  just
telling some myths and it, so I think
it's mostly people that are interested
in knowing how to learn languages.
I mean, I think that's super, uh, I think
the world of, of people like you and, and
like me, uh, making videos about language
learning and, and even, you know, English
is the one language where you really
have to get used to how people speak, who
are from different areas of the world.
Uh, if you're gonna learn French, you're
gonna either listen to a French person or
someone from Quebec, or if you're gonna
learn Portuguese, you're gonna listen
to someone from Portugal or Brazil.
And so forth and so on.
But with English, you have to get used
to understanding people from India, from
Singapore, from Australia, from, you know,
all, uh, from Bulgaria, from everywhere.
Not that you have a pronounced,
you know, Bulgarian accent, but I
think it's important that people
like you, uh, make these videos.
People watch them to improve, you
know, to get a better, you know,
sense of how to learn languages.
But also, I'm sure many people from
Brazil you mentioned, or other countries,
Bulgaria, will also be using these
videos to improve their English.
So we're part of the same community.
Uh, the world of language
learning has changed.
And, uh, thank you for joining me
here today and, um, hopefully we will
inspire more people to do the same.
Yeah.
Thank you so much for having me.
I'm a huge fan and I, I'm honored
to have been on your channel, Steve.
Thank you very much.
Bye for now.